[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und christian sievers
das schönste an tagen wie diesem ist der
abend guten abend ihnen allen dazu eine
gluthitze heute in teilen von
deutschland die heißeste nacht die je
gemessen wurde in großbritannien seien
meteorologisch ein paarmal hohe
temperaturen im hochsommer das allein
ist noch kein ausnahmezustand wenn wir
uns allerdings das große bild ansehen
die statistischen daten die dramatische
dürre in den böden dann sieht das
plötzlich ganz anders aus oder wie
forscher sagen es kann sein dass dies
der kälteste sommer ist für den rest
unseres lebens
wir sprechen gleich darüber was uns noch
enorm beschäftigen wird wenn die
hitzewelle längst vorbei ist erst luisa
houben und die ganz direkten folgen von
40 grad in deutschland
als pflegerin jenny wagner heute
vormittag bei ingrid ebel ankommt ist
eine ihrer ersten fragen
ramsey kennung getrunken sondern halten
die 81 jährige lebt in einer
dachgeschosswohnung ganz allein da kann
hitze richtig gefährlich werden und
jenny wagner macht sich sorgen ob die
wirklich genug trinken wenn wir nur
einmal am tag zu besuch kommen natürlich
ist leichter wenn familienmitglieder
im haushalt wohnen dass es leicht zu
kontrollieren hitze macht vor allem
alten und kranken zu schaffen kann
krämpfe oder kreislaufschwäche
begünstigen gar tödlich sein im jahr
2003 starben laut schätzungen
hitzebedingt in deutschland 9500
menschen vor vier jahren waren es
8700 wir sehen an einzelnen tagen und
dass es jetzt nicht die anzahl der
sterbefälle überschuss mortalität oder
die access mobilität es gibt schon
einzelne tagebuch praktisch 50 prozent
mehr todesfälle haar und genau macht um
die bevölkerung vor den hitze folgen zu
schützen sei vor allem gute
kommunikation gefragt einige städte wie
köln haben dafür extra hitze pläne
entwickelt empfehlen schatten luftige
kleidung wasser trinken an der orts aber
reiche der hitzeschutz nicht aus zum
beispiel häufig so dass gerade das
gesundheitswesen nicht aktiv beteiligt
ist und dadurch maßnahme pläne in
krankenhäusern und in pflegeheimen in
schulen und kindergärten zum beispiel
auch die sozialen einrichtungen nicht
unbedingt teil davon sind auf dauer
müssten städte und gebäude außerdem
umgebaut werden weniger beton und glas
stattdessen mehr grün dafür fordern
kommunen langfristige förderprogramme
jeder der realität vor augen sind spürt
ja sofort was für eine kühlende wirkung
dieses grün hat und das ist aber nicht
von heute auf morgen zu bekommen
brauchen lang hatten und da brauchen wir
auch unterstützung von bund und auch von
den ländern um diese dinge auch
finanzieren zu können ingrid ebel
verlässt sich an heißen tagen auf ihren
notfallknopf sollte ihr schummrig werden
könnte sie damit hilfe holen
die hitze ist das eine spüren wir sofort
und sehr massiv aber die trockenheit die
dürre die kommt schleichend und da sehen
wir halb europa seit mitte juli bereits
vor dort sieht sofort dort aus wie nach
einer monatelangen rekordsommer die zdf
wetterexperten katja horneffer ist bei
uns katja guten abend sie zeigen dass
eure da ja also deutlich zeigt sich das
im dürren monitor rot bedeutet dabei
extreme dunkelrot außergewöhnliche dürre
und außergewöhnlich da heißt nur in zwei
prozent der jahre 1951 bis 2015 war es
so knochentrocken wie jetzt diese
trockenheit hat sich in den letzten
wochen deutlich verschärft besonders im
nordosten und ganz im südwesten und
warum ist jetzt gerade diese trockenheit
so gefährlich und zwar dauerhaft
gefährlich jenseits von ein paar heißen
tagen naja weil sie folgen hat führt
jetzt schon zu früheren ernten und
geringeren erträgen und dabei schleppen
wir das wasserdefizit in vielen regionen
schon seit die dere sommer 2018 mit uns
herum so ausgetrockneten leichten
oberboden weht der wind einfach davon
wir wurden darunter ist bret hart wie
beton kann plötzliche wassermassen
gewitter mit starkregen nicht aufnehmen
da sickert nichts ein und wenn doch noch
lockerer oberboden da ist wird er
einfach weggespült langfristig sinkt
auch der grundwasserspiegel es fehlen
hunderte liter wasser pro quadratmeter
oder einfach mal ein halbes jahr ohne
besondere meteorologische vorkommnisse
das wäre schön herzlichen dank katja
horne war hier heute live bei uns im
studio
und jetzt weiter in der sendung mit der
politik russland und sein präsident sind
international isoliert und geächtet so
heißt es ja immer wieder aus den
hauptstädten der westlichen welt und das
ist auch sinn und zweck der politik dort
als antwort auf den russischen angriff
gegen die ukraine die realität sieht
aber doch anders aus da taucht heute in
teheran niemand anders auf als wladimir
putin zum gipfel treffen mit seinem
iranischen amtskollegen der schon seit
vielen jahren zeigt wie man als regime
trotz westlicher sanktionen immer
weitermachen kann außerdem dabei der
staatschef eines nato landes recep
tayyip erdogan aus der türkei offiziell
geht es um syrien tatsächlich mit
sicherheit auch um die ukraine um gas
und getreide das spezielle trio hat
sowohl unterschiedliche interessen als
auch gemeinsame ziele es lohnt sich den
mal genauer auf den grund zu gehen und
das macht jetzt glück war bot
die bühne war pompös drei staatschefs
fast beste freunde so die botschaft die
putin erdogan und reist gerne heute
abend in die welt senden möchten
tatsächlich geht es den drei alten
männern vor allem um eines die politisch
desolate position in die sie sich und
ihre staaten selbst gebracht haben durch
etwas glanz und taktische
partnerschaften abzumildern
allen voran der kriegsherr aus moskau
sanktionen setzen seiner wirtschaft zu
die kriegsverbrechen seiner reputation
putin gibt sich trotzdem gut gelaunt er
bringt geschenke mit sein energieriese
gazprom wird für 40 milliarden dollar
die maroden iranischen öl und erdgas
anlagen modernisieren über
gegenleistungen schweigt man sich aus
der iraner sei sie kennt das gefühl auf
internationaler bühne nicht willkommen
zu sein als staatsanwalt war er nach der
revolution an der massenhinrichtung
politischer gefangenen beteiligt jetzt
gibt er den präsidialen führer er
braucht putins militär um in syriens
diktator assad den iranischen
verbündeten an der macht zu halten und
erdogan der türkische staatschef möchte
in syrien wo er die islamistische
opposition unterstützt noch stärker
gegen die kurden vorgehen was aber die
beiden anderen herren entschieden
ablehne sich offen gegen putin stellen
will erdogan nicht zu groß ist die
abhängigkeit der inflations geplanten
türkei von russland immerhin kommt man
sich wirtschaftlich mit dem iraner reihe
ziehen er verstärkte zusammenarbeit
wurde vereinbart bei energie bei
technologie und bei wehrtechnik auch da
geht der nato-partner erdogan eigene
wege
wir wollen unser gegenseitiges
handelsvolumen von siebeneinhalb
milliarden auf 30 milliarden dollar
steigern
eine rasche friedenslösung für das
bürgerkriegs geschundene syrien wo alle
drei herren kräftig mitmischen ist nicht
in sicht nicht für eine neue syrische
verfassung nicht für eine rückkehr der
flüchtlinge nicht einmal für die
langfristige versorgung der vertriebenen
in syrien selbst der gipfel endet daran
wenig am späten abend werden die drei
staatschefs wohl auch über den
russischen krieg gegen die ukraine und
seine folgen sprechen hinter
verschlossenen türen mit ebenso
ungewissem ausgang
da stellen sich noch einige fragen
lösbar port guten abend 40 milliarden
schwerer kooperationsvertrag zwischen
russland und iran wir haben es gerade
gehört da hört man auch erst mal hin 40
milliarden ist ja nicht irgendeine summe
was konkret jenseits aller offiziellen
schweigsamkeit bekommt denn putin dafür
von miran
es gibt ja amerikanische meldungen aus
der letzten woche dass putin interesse
gezeigt hat an iranischen drohnen die
sind tatsächlich nicht nur vorhanden
sondern sollen militärisch auch ganz gut
sein ob das stimmt weiß man nicht der
iran hat das ganz offiziell übrigens
auch in einem telefonat beim
ukrainischen außenminister entrüstet
zurückgewiesen man liefere keine drohnen
an putin aber gut das ist die offizielle
stellungnahme darüber hinaus erhofft
sich putin sicherlich auch etwas know
how transfer und zwar in einem sehr
besonderen know-how nämlich wie man
sanktionen umschiffen kann der iran hat
da eine langjährige tradition unterhält
viele strohfirmen in aller welt die wenn
sie auffliegen werden da gleich wieder
neu gegründet auch gute kontakte zur
örtlichen banken also da könnte putin
sich einiges anschauen wie man trotz
isolation im internationalen
zahlungsverkehr weiter flüssig bleibt
und dann hat man sich ja so ein bisschen
die augen gerieben heute legt da trifft
sich ein nato staat mit einem nato
gegner was treibt denn den türkischen
präsidenten
ganz einfach eigeninteresse er will
maximale eigene vorteile für seine
politik und seine politischen ambitionen
herausschlagen und die sieht er im
konkreten fall eben in einer möglichen
achse eine art taktischen kurzfristigen
zusammenarbeit mit iran und russland er
ist sehr abhängig von russland der kann
sich nicht offen gegen putin stellen die
türkei bezieht weizen bezieht energie
bezieht aber auch viele devisen von
türkischen von russischen touristen nach
wie vor und deswegen ist das etwas
vorsichtig für ihn zu handhaben das
ganze aber er möchte ja in syrien weiter
gegen die kurdische pkk ableger
formationen also die milizen im norden
syriens vorgehen das möchten nur
naturgemäß weder putin noch ist sie weil
sie assad stützen und erdogan die
opposition also erdogan versucht hier
soviel rauszuschlagen wie eben kann dass
er als nato-mitglied damit zwei nato
gegnern am tisch sitzt stört ihn wenig
er sieht die nato auch nur als
kurzfristige sozusagen taktische
verbindung die er eingeht er fühlt sich
da nicht unbedingt an einen gemeinsamen
ja einen bündnisfall gebunden der ihn
irgendwie daran hindern würde mit putin
oder reis zu verhandeln glück war bot
der festhalle wo herzlichen dank für
diese analyse heute abend jetzt weitere
nachrichten von gundula darunter gleich
am anfang einer auf die wir sehr
gespannt warten ja nach allen sorgen
über einen möglichen stopp der
russischen gaslieferungen durch die
pipeline nord stream 1 gab es heute
berichte dass die lieferungen ab
donnerstag wieder aufgenommen werden
könnten nach abschluss der laufenden
wartungsarbeiten
mehrere nachrichtenagenturen bezogen
sich auf wie es heißt mit den plänen
vertraute quellen stefanie an der börse
der dax ging steil nach oben nachdem
spekulationen wie sehen denn die fakten
aus also es soll heute ein paar stunden
lang schon mal eine wirklich sehr
geringe menge an gas durch die
ostseepipeline nord stream 1 geströmt
sein das belegen wohl netzdaten des
pipelinebetreibers gazprom vielleicht
handelte es sich um einen test alles
noch unklar dann meldeten die
nachrichtenagenturen reuters und
bloomberg die russischen gaslieferungen
würden nach abschluss der
wartungsarbeiten
voraussichtlich wieder aufgenommen den
dax katapultierte die meldungen binnen
minuten um 3 prozent nach oben eine
solche kurve sieht man ja auch nicht
alle tage am ende blieb ein plus von
immerhin fast 350 punkten zuvor waren
energieversorger heute bereits gefragt
juniper erholte sich infolge der meldung
um zehn prozent rwe und e on ebenfalls
im plus wenn auch nicht ganz so stark
das energiethema schon tagsüber im fokus
deshalb auch interessant dass sich der
gaspreis heute leicht entspannt hat das
sehen wir eigentlich schon seit anfang
der woche und heute noch mal billiger
wenn auch natürlich weiter auf sehr
hohem niveau also hier ist man sehr
vorsichtig was diese meldungen angeht
man kennt putins taktik die nervosität
beim kritischen thema energie zu schüren
weiteres thema an der börse die hohe
inflation 8,6 prozent im euroraum im
juni was bedeutet das für die
angekündigte zins an übermorgen tag der
die ezb ja da überraschten heute
spekulationen die europäische
zentralbank könnte übermorgen die zinsen
doch kräftiger anheben als erwartet
bisher war ein plus von 0,25 prozent
angekündigt jetzt wird wohl in der ezb
offen über ein halbes prozent diskutiert
im grunde genommen sprechen wir
natürlich immer noch immer mit
zinserhöhungen aber der druck auf die
währungshüter steigt denn die heute
bestätigten inflationszahlen im euroraum
die rufe nach einer deutlicheren
reaktion mit 8,6 prozent hat die juni
inflation im euroraum nicht nur einen
neuen rekord erreicht sie ist damit gut
vier mal höher als das 2 prozent ziel
der ezb die baltischen staaten kämpfen
bereits mit teuerungsraten von teils
über 20 prozent in griechenland erreicht
sie im juni 11,6 prozent da stehen wir
in deutschland mit einer inflation von
8,2 prozent nach europäischer berechnung
noch im unteren mittelfeld immerhin
profitierte der euro heute bereits von
der aussicht auf einen großen
zinsschritt zeigte sich stabil über
einen dollar vielen dank stefanie nach
frankfurt
wegen des verdachts auf vorrat im
ukrainischen geheimdienst hat präsident
selensky weitere ranghohe mitarbeiter
der sicherheitsbehörden entlassen 28
geheimdienstler müssten gehen wegen des
vorwurfs der kollaboration mit den
russischen besatzern zugleich dauern die
russischen raketen angriffe an ziele
waren an diesem 146 tag des krieges grad
im osten und die region um odessa im
süden der ukraine zerstört wurde dort
nach angaben der russen ein
munitionslager für waffen aus den usa
und der eu
konkrete schritte im kampf gegen die
klimakrise hat bundesaußenminister in
bernburg zum abschluss des petersberger
klimadialogs in berlin angemahnt dieses
treffen diente der vorbereitung der
weltklimakonferenz im november in
ägypten dann müssten taten folgen
gemeinsam mit dem co gastgeber dem
ägyptischen aussenminister chocri
forderte sie zugleich ein sofortiges um
steuer vor dem hintergrund des
russischen angriffskrieges enttäuscht
äußerten sich umweltschutzorganisationen
die mehr initiative erwartet hatten und
in südeuropa bekämpfen weiterhin
tausende feuerwehrleute insbesondere in
spanien portugal und frankreich
großflächige waldbrände die dort seit
tagen wüten allein im südwesten
frankreichs wurden bisher 19.000 hektar
wald vernichtet heftige winde erschweren
die löscharbeiten im großraum london
standen ausgedörrte felder in flammen
die dann auf gebäude übergriffen
erstmals seit beginn der aufzeichnungen
in großbritannien wurden dort mehr als
40 grad gemessen
mit koste es was es wolle
das ist die politik der führung in china
auch wenn das unerbittliche
ausgangssperren bedeutet menschliche
dramen wirtschaftseinbruch und dennoch
steigende in flex infektionszahlen an
der politik wird nicht gerüttelt und
ohne die staatliche gesundheitsamt geht
nichts mehr wer keinen grünen code
vorweisen kann kommt in chinas
großstädten weder in supermärkte noch in
busse oder bahnen und manchmal nicht mal
mehr in die eigene wohnung der code
springt allerdings schon mal ganz
schnell von grün auf rot nicht etwa weil
ein test positiv gewesen wäre es reicht
offenbar an einer demonstration
teilnehmen zu wollen zumindest
beschweren sich immer mehr menschen über
willkür und politische kontrolle mittels
corona app miriam stein unsere china
korrespondentin hat ihre eigenen
erfahrungen gemacht es ist sehr früh und
es wird eine lange fahrt statt drei
stunden mit dem schnellzug fahren wir
acht mit dem auto mit einem zug ticket
müssten wir angeben wer wir sind und
wohin wir wollen genau das wollen wir
vermeiden
wir fahren nach john doe in die stadt in
der in den vergangenen wochen immer
wieder bankkunden demonstriert haben
wegen in einem der wohl größten
finanzskandale der letzten jahrzehnte
haben sie seit wochen keinen zugriff auf
ihr geld vor der kamera mit uns sprechen
möchte hier niemand aus angst vor
konsequenzen
einer hat uns erzählt als er an dem tag
der demo hier zu seinem laden kam war es
nur rund herum alles abgesperrt die
videos von der gewaltsamen auflösung der
demo die kannte er aber nicht obwohl
sein laden eigentlich nur 200 meter von
der bank entfernt ist ob das jetzt daran
liegt dass er glaubt dass es besser ist
davon nichts zu wissen oder daran dass
die zensur so schnell und so gründlich
gearbeitet hat das ist schwer zu sagen
es sind diese videos ein schlägertrupp
geht brutal gegen die bankkunden vor wo
sie vor ein paar tagen standen stehen
heute blumentöpfe
sie dürfen hier nicht filmen der staat
will die kontrolle über die bilder dies
sei ein sensibler ort berichterstattung
unerwünscht
als wir die stadt verlassen folgen uns
zwei der männer in zivil noch eine weile
in einem taxi
zurück nach peking dürfen wir nicht
schon seit der hinfahrt haben wir einen
warnhinweis in der korona app auch hier
geht es um kontrolle und die korona app
ist das werkzeug dafür
sie überwacht jede bewegung und ohne sie
geht nichts kein einlass im supermarkt
büro bus oder wohnkomplex unter dem
deckmantel der korona prävention bord
der chinesische präsident sieht den ping
seinen überwachungsstaat aus dafür nimmt
er sogar schlechte wirtschaftszahlen in
kauf vor allem der konsum seines landes
geht zurück
10 omikron varianten gibt es inzwischen
im land und in mehreren städten wie der
massentest und angst vor weiteren
lockdown die bedeuten für viele nämlich
auch keine arbeit kein gehalt das ist
problematisch für die kommunistische
partei die ihren führungsanspruch damit
legitimiert den lebensstandard des
volkes zu verbessern und schränkt die
null cobit politik in unserer täglichen
arbeit weiter ein wir sollen kontakt zu
einem verdachtsfall gehabt haben wann
und wo kann uns bisher niemand sagen wir
sollen warten das kann bis zu sieben
tage dauern
nochmal nachrichten
die europäische union hat die lange
blockierten beitrittsverhandlungen mit
den balkanstaaten nord mazedonien und
albanien eröffnet beide länder hätten
hart für diesen historischen moment
gearbeitet betonte eu kommissionschef in
von der leyen zuvor hatte nord
mazedonien einer verfassungsänderung
zugestimmt um bedenken des nachbarlandes
bulgarien dass die gespräche blockiert
hatte auszuräumen es werden langwierige
verhandlungen erwartet im tarifkonflikt
an den universitätskliniken in nordrhein
westfalen gibt es nach wochenlangem
streik eine lösung wäre die akzeptierte
einen entlastungs tarifvertrag ab januar
dabei werden bereichs bezogene
mindestvorgaben für den personaleinsatz
definiert deren unterschreitung mit
freizeit ausgeglichen werden soll mit
fast 80 streik tagen hatte wäre die
bessere arbeitsbedingungen in den
unterbesetzten klinik bereichen
eingefordert tausende operationen
mussten wegen personalknappheit
verschoben werden zum radsport die
sechzehnte etappe der tour de france hat
der kanadier
gewonnen diesen ersten etappensieg für
kanada seit 34 jahren widmete er seinem
bruder der bei einem verkehrsunfall ums
leben gekommen war knapp 180 kilometer
ging es heute bei über 30 grad von
carcassonne nach vor in den pyrenäen
geld verteidigte souverän der däne jonas
wie new york und weiter erfolgreich im
gepunkteten trikot kämpft simon geschke
aus berlin bei der tour und den ersten
deutschen titel
bei der leichtathletik-wm in den usa
macht das deutsche diskuswerferinnen
trio hoffnung auf eine erste medaille
für deutschland
olympia zweite kristin pudenz steht
neben clou den vita und shanice craft im
finale am donnerstag
enttäuschung dagegen bei hochsprung
europameister mateusz przybylko er
landete mit 224 nur auf rang 12 gold
gewann zum dritten mal in folge der
katarer bachschmid souveränen zweimeter
37 und das ohne fehlversuch
selbst wer der opernwelt höchstens mal
beim trällern unter der dusche näher
kommt oder wenn eine leckere pasta sauce
auf dem herd köchelt weiß bei diesen
bildern sofort was los ist bregenzer
festspiele vor einzigartiger see und
bergkulisse tosca kamen natürlich
rigoletto und meist fahren sie schon
beim bühnenbild gewaltig auf morgen
startet der opernsommer 2022 am bodensee
dieses mal eine nummer schlichter fast
schon
minimalistisch für bregenz verhältnisse
mit einem liebesdrama madame butterfly
claudio armbruster hat die bilder dazu
und die klänge natürlich
am anfang einer jeden geschichte steht
das leere blatt papier dieses hier ist
halt besonders groß die seebühne in
bregenz muss groß sein für 7000
zuschauer pro aufführung da ist die
intime liebesgeschichte der madame
butterfly nicht einfach zu inszenieren
ein stück was eigentlich wo man denkt
introvertierter ist aber ein kammerspiel
ist aber gleichzeitig ist das budget und
puccini ist immer großes kino wenn man
so will also große emotionen ist
immerhin unglaublich vergrößert und das
hat uns dann auch bestärkt in dem wunsch
und in der ig dass hier tatsächlich zu
machen
madame butterfly ist die geschichte der
japanischen
gauchos an die von dem amerikanischen
marine leutnant pinkerton
verführt
[Musik]
geheiratet
geschwängert und dann schnell ich sitzen
gelassen wird
das ist ein wirklich erbärmliche figur
natürlich ist ein tenor
und am ende er weiß dass ich aber als
als vollkommener versager deswegen
tenöre die rolle oft nicht so gern
singen
manche sagen er ist ein netter kerl und
unglücklicherweise ist das wirklich
einer dieser seltenen rollen indem ich
eine nicht sehr sympathischen charakter
spiele
andererseits in dieser musik von puccini
zu schwimmen das ist die größte freude
[Musik]
mit allen musikalischen farben der liebe
von überglücklich bis untröstlich
wirklich große musik ist es ja wirklich
fast wie viel musik komponiert und
dadurch entsteht auch diese nähe
zwischen dem blatt papier und der musik
ist wird nicht wie eine leinwand
eingesetzt aber durch wie wir und licht
kommt die leinwand zum leben sehr
politisch sehr fein sehr mag ich es
nenne und das gibt dann dem ganzen diese
verstärkung der emotion
[Musik]
das anfangs weißen blatt papier
wird zur leinwand für den liebestod
einen sommer lang am bodensee
die farben der liebe auf der seebühne
der kollege claus kleber hat viel
gesehen und erlebt und ist dabei immer
neugierig geblieben er rechnet mit allem
und lässt sich dennoch gerne überraschen
wenn einer wie er von einer reise
zurückkommt mit glänzenden augen voll
gepackt mit geschichten verwundert und
verstört zugleich und wenn klaus dann
anbietet uns alle mitzunehmen in die
zukunft unserer welt dann sollten wir
das nicht verpassen heute abend 23 uhr
hier im zdf
großkonzerne stecken gerade ihre claims
ab keiner so entschlossen wie facebook
mit
zuckerberg will dass der so in sein
imperium
unwiderstehlich wird
ein raum ohne grenzen in denen man
eintaucht wie in einen rausch virtuell
mit haut und haar
[Musik]
es ist unmöglich dieses internet der
zukunft in ein bild zu fassen
[Musik]
es war nicht einfach den guru der
virtualität für ein interview über
silicon valleys heißes thema zu gewinnen
dabei hat er in lenny das totale
eintauchen ins internet erfunden bevor
das internet überhaupt existierte er hat
virtueller realität ihren namen gegeben
sie ist sein kind und jetzt plagen ihn
sorgen dass mächtige des missbrauchs
[Musik]
utopia ist eine reise in eine zukunft
die längst begonnen hat auch wenn das
kaum jemand von uns wirklich realisiert
mit dem heutigen abend sollte sich das
ändern
utopia 23 uhr hier im zdf oder jederzeit
auch jetzt schon in der zdf mediathek
und mit diesem heißen fernsehteam
entlassen wir sie in eine heiße
sommernacht bis morgen und das aber
nicht ohne den hinweis auf unser
heute-journal update gegen 23.45 mit
christopher wehrmann
[Musik]
guten abend damit die hitze weg geräumt
würde gebrauch des tiefs vom westen und
genauso eines kommt hier auch heran das
bringt morgen schon regenschauer und
gewitter aber leider nicht genug regen
um die dürre einhalt zu gebieten aber
schauer und gewitter sind ja auch schon
mal was morgen vormittag geht das los
über frankreich über belgien und den
niederlanden und bis zum mittag
erreichen diese ersten regenschauer dann
auch deutschland am nachmittag weiten
die sich außer können gewitter dabei
sein die ziehen über rheinland-pfalz und
nordrhein-westfalen und auch über baden
württemberg und bayern in der nacht zu
donnerstag ziehen diese gewitter dann
weiter richtung nordosten und osten
erreichen auch hamburg und münchen die
kommende nacht wird erstmal verbreitet
tropisch die temperaturen sinken also
nicht unter 20 grad besonders belastend
wird es wohl in den großen städten
nordrhein westfalens sein da sinken die
werte nicht unter 23 grad angenehmer
wird die nacht an der ostsee und auch in
bayern mit spritzen oder 13 grad und die
hitze blase erreicht ja morgen den
nordosten 40 grad gibt es dann richtung
berlin brandenburg thüringen sachsen
anhalt vielleicht sogar in hamburg in
besten ist es etwas kühler bei 28 bis 30
grad aber da die luftfeuchte und schwül
wird kommt uns das auch sehr unangenehm
vor schon am vormittag beginnt es ja mit
den ersten regenschauern die weiten sich
dann zum späten nachmittag und abend aus
im osten bleibt es dagegen einfach nur
sonnig in den nächsten tagen weitere
schauer und gewitter aber nicht genug
und es wird deutlich kühler freitag und
samstag liegen die werte bei 18 bis 32
grad guten abend